foreign
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to Planet coaster and
welcome back to aerobats of Arabia today
I'm going to work on the memluk main
street but this name doesn't really
represent what I'm building because it's
more of a Riverfront area as well just
like the last episode except this one is
going to be Egyptian themed now I'm
going to go into that in a little bit
more detail later because first I'm
trying something completely different
and it's something that I've never tried
in Planet coaster before in its Moroccan
architecture and I discovered that
there's plenty of pieces in the game and
the theme makers toolkit items to figure
out how to make the details and shapes
and colors and textures of this kind of
architecture in this game and I'm kind
of obsessed with it recently because
it's just really cool and something so
different from what I've done before and
that's what this series is all about by
the way to be very honest I've gotten a
lot of comments about me always building
Japanese and Alpine maybe some steampunk
Parks here and there and it's getting
repetitive well no more I want to try
and Branch out to as many different
architectural Styles as I can with this
series and I'm also just realizing how
much fun it is that said hours and hours
of research actually goes into this
which sounds like I'm taking this game
way too seriously but to be very honest
it's also just really enjoyable I find
there's a lot of fun in searching up new
types of architecture new sites and
cities and figuring out how they work
and I think one of the best ways to
learn about things is to try and do it
yourself so in this case it's just a
really cool way to figure out how the
intricacies of certain architectures and
cities work and it's all part of the the
journey I'd say now that said about
Moroccan architecture there are various
styles of Moroccan architecture you have
kind of more of the Inland Berber kind
of architecture or uh the alma had kind
of architecture that you find along the
seaside there are cities with completely
different city centers in terms of the
colors and textures used but in this
case I am just going to try and blend
them together at some point in the
future I'm not exactly sure how I'm
going to figure everything out when I
get to more Moroccan architecture
because they're certainly going to beat
a lot more of it in this area but for
now I'm just focusing on this one
building and this one's quite
representative because it's more or less
following the basic model of all mosques
or at least minarets in Morocco now a
typical Moroccan minarets will consist
of a square Tower and on top of which is
placed a kind of cylindrical Tower with
some finials or a spire on top of it and
that's really it it's a very basic shape
and no matter what kind of major city in
Morocco you look up you you'll find many
of those kinds of minarets so that's
probably the best way to represent
Morocco and make it very recognizable
instantly
and I think getting to the core of
whatever architectural symbolism is
typical for whichever country is going
to be very important for this whole area
because I'm mixing up so many different
countries we have the Persian wind
towers and in the near future we have
some Egyptian areas and then we also
have Morocco and to the average person
who doesn't spend hours on Wikipedia
like I like to do I think it's going to
be very difficult to tell those apart so
there I will definitely have to use some
tricks to make them a bit more memorable
and recognizable and that all starts out
with this building
now what I'm working on here is um I
started off with the archways which I
wanted to cross the path with because
this is just something that I was
planning for a while I wanted some kind
of uh Gallery over there crossing the
path and then over here I'm working on
the tower of the minarets well it's the
tower itself but uh the lower Square
tower part of it and um something fun to
say about this one is that it uses a
very particular decoration pattern which
is also called a sepka I've recently
learned which also just means net which
refers to well you can probably tell it
kind of looks like a net texture down
there and it's a very common interlacing
Motif that you find in Moroccan
architecture
um and I figured it was doable to do
this thing with some very thin supports
I believe those support beams are made
by Hydro not entirely sure by the way
um on Twitter I posted a link to my
steam collection where save all of my
theme makers toolkit items I've been
getting many questions about which items
I use and how to keep up to date with
them so just go over to my Twitter it's
twitter.com silverette and you can find
the link over there everything I use in
this series is included in that as well
as some other tidbits I use in some
other videos plus I think they're all
very good items to use I try to only
stick to those the makers toolkit items
that are actually useful because I know
how easy it is to fall into that trap of
getting too many items all at once so um
yeah I'd recommend following the
collection or at least checking it out
for yourself and see if there's anything
interesting in there I find that because
the theme makers toolkit is not used
that much and because Planet coaster is
not that popular of a game anymore many
of these items end up being kind of
underrated so I'm trying to bring some
appreciation to how much they managed to
change the game and I think this type of
Architecture is one example of that this
building would have never been possible
without the makers toolkit be it the
sapka patterns that I made with the
pillars then on the top section of the
square part here I used some wallpaper
and decoration items from theme makers
toolkit that I think make a huge
difference as well and then for the
decorations on the roof line there the
little Battlement like decorations I
also used some small bricks from the
theme makers toolkit so none of these
things would have been possible with the
theme makers toolkit I also find some
people arguing that sticking with
vanilla items is more creative in a
sense because you have to sort of use
very creative ways to to figure out how
to make things with certain pieces you
know you have to figure out how to make
what you want with a very limited amount
of pieces but honestly I tend to
disagree with that because as you can
see you can use the makers toolkit items
in completely different ways from what
they're supposed to as well and make
some things that you wouldn't be able to
make without them so while I think
there's certainly a difference between
just dragging the makers toolkit items
into the game and not really adding or
changing much about it which by the way
is also fine because whatever way you
want to play the game is fine of course
it's just the way that you enjoy it and
everybody should be able to enjoy it the
way they like but you know I think
there's a lot of creativity involved
even if you're using custom pieces if
not more so creativity
that's that's all a horrible sentence
but you know what I mean because there
are so many more mixes and matches that
you can do and
um yeah with every new piece you add the
amount of possibilities just
exponentially increases
that all said I probably should talk a
bit about what I've been building here
so I finished the top part of the
minaret as well and with that it really
has achieved that kind of uh yeah
typical architecture for the area I
think
and now it's time to finish the gallery
that's crossing the pathway over here
another fun thing that I think is worth
pointing out the Arches that I placed
below there are also referred to as
polyloped arches because they have all
of those little decorations now to be
fair these aren't quite as decorated as
they can be in real life where they can
have very detailed carvings everywhere
but the point is you see all of those
different lobes and it's a it's a style
that would typically be used for more
decorative buildings so mosques and
palaces and that kind of thing so I
think for this building it's very
fitting and it's a fun way to also come
up with you know a different type of
arch every time I want to build arches
somewhere there's just something so cool
about making those themed elements like
arches and domes inspires and figuring
out how you can do it each one a little
bit differently every time you get to
build one
now that is more or less it for the musk
building here but one thing that I
should probably say is that I wanted to
connect this building somehow to this
facade on the other side to the the shop
building that I built in the last
episode because that was the whole plan
for this area I wanted the shop building
to extend and cross the path into the
facade on the other side so that we have
lots of buildings and we can really make
this feel like you're walking through a
city
the only problem I had with this is that
once I built it I realized that it
didn't really work out in the
composition that I was going for now the
composition was kind of simple to have
two tower-like elements on both sides of
the Arches crossing the pathway and then
um yeah you have the arches in the
middle and one tower on one side and now
that's the wind Catcher from the shop
and another tower-like building on the
other side but after building this
minarets I realized it's too tall and
too detailed compared to this wind
catcher over here and I think it's just
attracting all of the attention to
itself which is not really working out
from a compositional standpoint and yes
I am going to talk about composition
again because after the last episode the
last episode I'm I'm still not done
um So eventually I decided not to scrap
this building but I moved it to a
different location and I wanted to
figure out a different way to
get to what I wanted to do and make it
fit into the area a little bit better
and I think this all works out fine
actually in the end because I moved the
minarets to a different location where I
wanted to build Moroccan architecture
more anyway so I think that works out
um but it just means that you know
sometimes the buildings have to be moved
to a different location now N7 can
probably say a lot about this but I
think it's never a bad thing to look at
what you've built and see if things
actually work out because sometimes you
can have the most beautiful buildings
but they just don't really work out next
to each other and that's something that
ended up happening here so for the
better of the composition of this whole
area I decided to work on this building
again and give it a more Egyptian touch
and instantly move to the Egyptian style
that I wanted to do for this row of
buildings now this means that this
building is a little bit lower and a
little bit smaller and a little bit less
detailed than the minaret tower but the
overall picture it creates and
especially looking from the bridge which
is still a very important Viewpoint I
think it just works out a little bit
better now also something that I think
is worth pointing out whenever theme
parks do Egyptian theme themed areas we
typically get to see pyramids and
ancient Egyptian themes and while I
think that's very interesting in this
whole series I kind of want to focus
more on architecture from the last few
centuries especially architecture from
the late 19th century which I think you
know capturing late 19th century from
everywhere is really cool because you
get to incorporate lots of Revival
architecture elements and it's just
before modern architecture came up and
started replacing most of the old Styles
there are lots of discussions to be
ahead about that and while I don't think
modern architecture is bad per se I'm
just a huge fan of 19th century
architecture and especially for theme
parks and trying to transport people
into the kind of Make-Believe better
than the real world world uh I think
it's uh it's basically my favorite
um now this specifically is a horror of
buildings that's going to be inspired by
mum look architecture which is from the
mamluk sultanate between the 13th and
the 16th century in Egypt so not quite
ancient Egyptian but still very Egyptian
I would say and it's a style that
continues to have a huge influence in
historic Cairo where you can still find
many buildings that are reminiscent of
that style or simply from that era it's
also from my brief look into the history
of Egypt the most prosperous era of
Egypt in recent decades or centuries I
should say
um so just a really fun style and I
think it also manages to have a very
good connection to the architecture
that's already in this area the Middle
Eastern and Persian architecture because
it just manage manages to transition
very seamlessly into that and then on
the other side we can transition into
Moroccan architecture and it all should
work out pretty well now the reason this
works well with the buildings that are
already in this area is because we get
to use similar colors and similar shapes
of buildings but the detailing is
definitely very different and I think
one of the best ways to tell this
already is by the use of the different
layers of stone in different colors of
stone as you can tell
I'm not actually using wall pieces well
I am using some wall pieces but I am
using some of the detail pieces to
create different layers of bricks in
different colors and when looking at
pictures from Cairo and similar cities
built in this style you can find this a
lot different layers of sandstone and
sometimes even different types of
materials which provide a really
interesting texture to walls and the
same goes for arches and any decorative
elements they'll have some lighter and
some darker Stones as well so that's
something that I'm going to play around
with a lot in this area and another
thing that changes but is kind of a
little bit similar is the use of wood
and especially Oreo windows I found that
there is a huge amount of wooden
carvings and things like that all over
the buildings of this style in Cairo and
especially on the Oreo Windows which you
see everywhere so the Oreo windows are
coming back from the areas that I've
already built in this park because I've
built quite a few of them but in this
part we'll have some more and we'll have
some other wooden decorations on top of
that as well
one of them is this roof Ridge over here
which I find is very common on many
buildings in Cairo especially some of
the drinking fountain buildings uh
something that you find in a lot of
ultimate architecture but just in
general in the Middle Eastern Area is a
public water fountains with their own
designated buildings and I think it
makes a lot of sense because they have a
very important public function
especially in that part of the world
where the climate isn't so forgiving but
they're typically very decorated
buildings and they really stand out in
their area they have a lower section
where some doors can open up to water
fountain or dispenser or whatever
um and then some higher sections with
lots of details and sometimes also some
wooden carvings and roof ridges just
like the one that I've built just here
so reminiscent of that style is how I
ended up building this building and then
the next few buildings in in this row
are going to be similar but slightly
different to the buildings that I've
built so far in this whole area so a bit
more wood a bit more different brick
colors a bit darker all in general
um but it also manages to fit with the
overall area
and this is something that I was trying
to go for as much as possible so when
you're standing on the bridge for
instance and you can see the whole area
you can see that the colors of the
materials the shapes of buildings and
the items used they all kind of fit
together but you can kind of see a
transition happening from one side to
the other and the way that I imagine
this at some point in the future is that
if you stand on the bridge and you look
towards the lift Hills of the coasters
on the left you can see some ottoman
architecture and then it shifts to kind
of
um Modern Day Middle Eastern
architecture some Persian influences and
then you go down to Egypt with still
very similar colors and building types
but you can slightly see it shifting and
then when you move your view all the way
to the right you can see the beginning
of the Moroccan area which is once again
similar but different and hopefully
that's going to end up end up working
out and everything will look similar
enough to look like one Giant themed
area from a distance but once you get
really into a ground level and into some
specific streets and plazas of different
areas you can tell the difference and
you can tell that you're in a slightly
different area at least that's the goal
that I'm going for with this uh this
whole park
and I think it's uh it's also a way that
I just have to approach this because I
want to try out so many different
architecture Styles I think most theme
parks in real life would have just
caught this whole area a generic Arabian
architecture area and just mixed and
meshed all kinds of Arabian themes in a
kind of orientalist way
but in this series I'm trying not to be
about that that said obviously I'm still
looking at all of this from a western
perspective and this is still a theme
park so everything is still quite
fantasy and I'm not an expert on any of
these styles of architecture and I think
that probably deserves to be calling out
because it definitely means that they're
not going to be super uh realistic or
accurate and it's always my own
interpretation of what these things are
like that said I'm trying to be more
realistic than theme parks because in
theme parks in the real world YouTube
typically see that these things are very
very botched in a sense and if you look
into certain types of styles of
architecture you typically find that in
theme parks they're a little bit
different and you can always see that
they're not entirely accurate although
there are some exceptions I think I
think the World Showcase in Disney is a
really good example and also a good
inspiration I think whenever you're
trying to do Blanco builds with
different styles of different countries
and Fantasia land sometimes does it very
well too I think the Chinese area in
Fantasia land is amazing
uh so those are some examples that come
to mind but most of them even Disney
sees Arabian Coast which was part of the
inspiration for this park is a little
bit of a mishmash of all kinds of
different things it's a bit hard to pin
down exactly what it's trying to be and
it's definitely a fantasy uh kind of
Arabian architecture not entirely
realistic that said that's also not a
critique of it in any way that's just
how it is because it is beautiful and I
love DisneySea and it's still a huge
influence on this park and part of what
makes this park uh fun to work on and I
should be very careful I'm already
naming this a park but you know that
that all has to do with whether my
computer can manage it and I got some
questions about that in the last episode
my computer should be more than good
enough to handle just about anything in
this game
um because I got a new computer recently
and it's pretty good
but you know Planet coaster doesn't have
the uh the very best performance once
you start adding all of these elements
and I also shouldn't critique the game
too much over that because I'm doing
things with this game that you're really
not supposed to and adding so many theme
makers toolkit items and you know when
you're building domes out of thousands
of pieces really who should you blame
when your game starts lagging it's
probably myself but you know I I wanna
not have to uh skip out on any details
but I also want to see if I can turn
this into a full Park so you know that's
the Dilemma
anyway we're moving into the last part
of this video uh and I say that because
this is the last row of facades and once
again I'm trying out some new way to
make a nice horseshoe Arch
um although this isn't really a horsey
watch this is just a pointy one
um I think I haven't really gotten
around to the discussion of different
types of arches yet but we'll do that in
the future uh for now it's good to know
that a horseshoe Arch is basically as
the name says it's those kind of Arabian
arches or at least the type of arch that
many people associate with Arabian
architecture where it curves a little
bit inwards before it moves down to the
pillars that support the arch and it's
very common in all kinds of Arabian
architecture but the same goes for this
pointy style of building arches and then
also the polylobed arch as well so with
those different Arch types that aren't
regular round arches and mixing them up
a little bit you can very quickly start
creating an Arabian in vibe to an area
now this is going to house a small
restaurant actually I haven't talked
about the actual function of these
buildings yet but yes I am going to do
more interiors and no I'm not sure how
well this is going to go but I really
want to make sure that all of my
buildings in this park actually have a
function and I'm not just building the
exteriors which has always been a huge
trap of mine I ended up always building
kind of useless buildings I think in
Jaeger horn I put some stalls in there
but nothing much in terms of interiors
and yeah that's about it there are some
Interiors in volvara surely there are
some small Interiors in the quality
Beach but most of my builds haven't
really had Interiors yet and I think
it's kind of a shame and for this park
to really feel immersive and like it
could be a real Park I definitely should
have some realistic Interiors in certain
area in certain areas plus it also helps
to make the Park View alive if you can
walk around in it and actually visit the
buildings and have some signs of life
outside the buildings like signs to
restaurants and entrances to restaurants
or toilets or whatever it just makes the
whole park feel better from the outside
as well
so yeah we're doing interiors and this
building specifically is going to house
a small restaurant now I should use the
word restaurant kind of loosely because
when I want to build big restaurants I
think it's better to put them on the
outskirts of the park as well or at
least at a place where you can hide most
of the restaurant building in this case
it's in the middle of a themed area and
it's kind of helping to provide all of
these facades with a lively indoor
section so this is just going to be a
simple Take Out restaurant where you can
get fries and stuff like that
honestly if Planet coaster had Kebab
this would definitely be where I sold
Kebab unfortunately that's not quite in
the game as far as I'm aware so you know
I I can request things but I don't think
they're gonna be added into the game at
this point anymore but you know a man
can dream let's just pretend that there
are amazing dinner kebabs somewhere in
this building
and man I should shut up about that
because I really could go for one now
anyway I built a tower just now that
also didn't quite work out uh the way I
was uh trying to make it work out uh it
just felt way too small so I ended up
building another Tower here and this
Tower is a little bit interesting as
well because it kind of looks like it's
on a full tile but it's a little bit
smaller so everything on this building
has to be built kind of separately and
piece by piece and it's a little bit of
a hassle but I think it's worth it for
once again the overall composition of
this area it manages to give it some
forced perspective as well because it
looks like a full a full-sized building
but it's a lot smaller than it seems and
especially in this game where everything
seems like a full tile when it's just a
little bit less than a full tile it
really helps to sell the force
perspective I think or at least that was
the idea with this building now this
little Tower doesn't really have a
function other than the fact that this
is the corner so this is where I want
some of my most detailed and interesting
architecture to be and then between this
and the other Corners there's mostly
going to be some filler architecture
some small separate facades with some
roofs and windows and doors and
decorations here and there but nothing
too involving like this Tower here with
its custom arches and detailed roof line
and
everything that it has
now to come back to the discussion about
not using your buildings and saving them
somewhere on the park file and then
using them at some later stage this is
also going to be another example because
you might remember that in the first
episode I built this minaret-like Tower
with a red spire and I ended up throwing
that thing away because I really
couldn't come up with a way to make that
thing look good it just looked kind of
out of place where I originally built it
so I threw it somewhere in the park file
hoping to hold on to it you can actually
see it in the background just a few
seconds ago while I was moving to the
other place in the park to try and copy
that Oreo window
[Music]
um but yeah so I had that thing built
and it really didn't work out where it
was and then at some point I wanted to
figure out what kind of Dome or aspire
to build on top of this corner building
here because I didn't want to keep the
roof completely flat because it just
kind of looked like something was
missing and then at some point I decided
to sync that Tower from episode 1 into
the roof of this building and just slap
it on top of this and it just worked out
perfectly like it was so good then I I
don't know it was kind of kind of hard
to believe just how perfectly it works
so
all that just to say that whenever you
build a building no matter how proud you
are of it if it doesn't really work in
its area and you're looking at it like
I'm not entirely sure just throw that
thing away well don't throw it away but
throw it somewhere else hold on to it
and remember that you've still got that
unused building and whenever you're in
another area of your park or in the same
area but trying to build a different row
of facades and you're stuck just slap
that thing in there and see if it works
out and sometimes that results in the
best Solutions so yeah with that said
I'm gonna move lots of buildings around
in this whole area because I have an
idea of what the area is going to look
like but not exactly what the details
are going to be in which place so
that's the last lesson for today I want
to thank you guys for watching I hope
you guys enjoyed this episode and I'll
see you in the next one
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]